Cindy is with us in Houston Texas
hi Cindy how are you good how about you
better than I deserve what's up well me
and my husband are currently working
baby the baby steps one baby step number
two and I'm sorry I'm under the weather
okay we recently celebrated our 30th
wedding anniversary yay yay and with
that he went out and purchased me this
beautiful wedding anniversary ring and
put it on credit and it's $4,000
additional and I'm torn between keeping
it I'm returning it I understand how his
brain works I thought you said the two
of you were working on a plan to get out
of that I thought we were too yes I'm
more concerned about the fact that he's
not on this plan than I am the ring I
agree because I mean next week he's
going to finance power tools and then
he's gonna come on with a new mass boat
three weeks from now
there you go there you go let's finance
that $6,000 John Deere lawn mower you
might be a redneck if you have payments
on your riding mower you know I mean
seriously see the breakdown yes the
breakdown is we can't get out of a hole
while we're digging out the bottom so
I'm a lot more concerned about his lack
of grasp that this was the family goal
that I am whether or not you keep this
ring mm-hmm personally I take it back I
mean I've been married 35 years and it's
just you know it'd be nice to have a
nice ring and you can get you another
ring I mean there's just stupid rings
everywhere I mean it's not a big thing
it's not like it's your wedding ring or
something it was a an anniversary gift
that you all couldn't afford exactly and
hey I mean sweet but dumb you know right
yes so but I think the thing is here
yeah I'm probably taking it back but
more importantly I want to take his
brain and screw it back in a little bit
better you
and the two of y'all decide are we
really doing this or not because
otherwise you're never gonna get there
because apparently he's not on the same
page you're on that's big thing I mean
90% of this question is around that ten
percents on whether to keep the ring or
not see and so this ring is not gonna
make or break your get out of debt plan
one way or the other but this behavior
will and this lack of being on the same
page will so you know let's just talk
this through and make sure we're on the
same page and then you guys decide
together what to do with the ring and I
don't know I it just represents dumb and
so I'm not ever gonna really be able to
enjoy it if I'm you because it's just in
violation of where you thought your
whole family was heading it's like just
kind of you know you guys are just too
old to do that kind of stuff so I mean
that's the 20 year old stuff right there
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]